It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not awake, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm very awake, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
Half of us is sleepy.
Half of us isn't.
Yes.
Good.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us for our 159th episode of FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
I can be just a...
Awake and hanging in.
And you can be the awake and ready to conquer the day!
Who's gonna be the host?
You have to be awake!
Moco-chan is the host.
I'm awake.
BAU BAU!
You know what my hidden secret was?
FUWAMOCO-chan.
It was just passing out for a couple minutes and then waking up.
I have lots of dreams so then that counts for a full night's sleep, right?
Dream corner, Moco-chan!
Oh.
True, but I sort of forgot them.
I didn't write them down.
But I'm pretty sure that, uh... It was either Nerissa or Gigi, but... I can't remember.
What?
But what, Moco-chan?
In my dream!
Huh?
It was Nerissa.
And?
Nane-chan.
Oh, and?
What happened?
I don't know.
I can't remember.
I think I got in trouble and misunderstood something.
Thanks, Moco-chan.
You're welcome!
Well, for those that are joining us for the first time, this is a show about dreams.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
I'm laughing because this is like the sleepiest you've ever sounded.
Is it?
For those that are joining us today for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a 24 minute morning show!
I'm sorry I can't let you sound like that!
I'm sorry I can't!
FUWAMOCO!
Hi.
Yeah, that was the suggestion, right, Moco-chan?
What?
That'd be the corner where Fuwawa goes home early.
The episode where he's like, okay, time for me to leave now, huh?
FUWAMOCO Morning has two hosts, right, Moco-chan?
BAU BAU!
And Ruffians, we're gonna start off the day on the right paw today!
Wait, Moco-chan!
We have some exciting things to share with the Ruffians!
My photos at breakfast is just like last time, right?
Ruffians like sending us photos at breakfast.
Breakfast photos?
I like that.
This time it's not a breakfast photo.
What are you eating for breakfast today, Ruffians?
This time it's not a breakfast photo!
I'm just trying to visualize it, okay?
What are you eating?
You're eating breakfast right now, right?
I'm eating cucumbers.
What is breakfast?
Breakfast can be anything that neutralizes your body for the day.
What?
Neutralizes?
Anything that neutralizes your body, okay?
You should have more than air.
Like a cucumber.
Today is a cucumber kind of day.
Yes!
Eggs, avocado, bacon, that's neutralizing.
Ah!
Cucumbers too.
I think the cucumber will be a very good breakfast today.
Yes!
Neutralizing, okay?
Well, it's FUWAMOCO's breakfast sighting today, Moco-chan.
Well, um... Unfortunately, it's not breakfast and that's why I feel a bit off already.
I was looking forward to breakfast.
I'm not very neutralized by this next... next photo we have to share.
Is it not a breakfast sighting, Moco-chan?
It's not a breakfast sighting, it's a Pero sighting!
I thought we could maybe change things up, you know, just look at the ruffians' breakfasts, but... Okay, well it was Pero sighted then, Moco-chan.
Pero-chan!
It's a computer.
Computer?
That's pretty good, even better.
You know computers are strong.
Yes, maybe he'll like it there.
This looks like a really cool computer.
It's a small computer but it also looks like one that maybe has...
Ladies with names of computers in them.
Ah, old computers, yeah!
Maybe he can stay there for a long time.
Don't you know?
What computer is this?
Ruffians, do you know?
I think it's ancient.
Virus?
Pero's a virus?
I don't know.
Caramel Pain Pero!
Windows 98?
Is it a 98?
Is this like a laptop?
That's very ancient!
Ruffians!
I was looking at this.
I'm thinking, wait, huh?
Is this?
Moco-chan, do you remember?
I didn't remember until you brought it up!
A WAPRO!
Is it a Japanese word processor?
WAPRO!
Is this a WAPRO?
FUWAMOCO!
We learned how to type in Japanese with a WAPRO as part of our Japanese lessons!
And I forgot about that until... 10 minutes ago.
I've used a WAPRO before!
I'm not too sure exactly what a WAPRO is versus just a...
A laptop computer.
A word processor.
Everything's a word processor, right?
Yes, so then what exactly is a word processor, right?
I don't know, but I like old computers.
I don't really get them, but you can play old games on them.
Right, and you know, it kind of takes you back to a different world.
I don't know what would be a word processor.
Maybe Pero's lucky.
Right.
Yeah, but you can stay in there.
Ask Inaz!
She's a waburo!
That was a really good one.
I like that a lot.
Yeah, but I do have one thing to say.
I think your computer is dead.
Maybe.
It doesn't matter.
It can't do anything anymore, be it games, word pricing.
Speaking of a waffle... It was her birthday and she celebrated it with a feety birthday concert!
FUWAMOCO Morning.
I'm sure that was the intention, huh?
Right, right!
It's super duper cute!
It's Ina-senpai's hero outfit!
Yeah, she definitely looks like a hero.
It's really cute!
But in their performances, you know, she had amazing, amazing songs sung together with Akirose-senpai!
Shari!
It was really nice, you know, seeing the two of them dancing.
Ina-senpai...
Shaking and swaying like that.
You know, a song together with Peri-senpai and then with Watame-senpai and Botan-senpai too.
Unfortunately.
We had to dash away with coins or we had things that we needed to get done and things that were calling us right away.
We were not happy about this.
I was not happy and especially so because
Only later did I find out that Ina-senpai, she sung one of my favorite songs!
Yes!
Yes, did you know it?
Yeah, it's from Nature Plus' visual mode, Rawr Chorus.
Yes!
And it's sung originally by Ina Kaneko, and I just, I couldn't believe it!
It's one of my favorite Ina Kaneko songs!
I always sing it at karaoke, and I don't think anybody knows about this song!
Yes!
Because we were trying to get...
Karaoke part for over a year, yes!
But all this, Ina-senpai, she sung it for me, right?
Yes.
You thought nobody knows?
No!
That's- it's because she did it for me.
Yeah.
She did it for me.
It was just for us, okay?
You know, I really really wonder, you know, why did she chose it?
Where did she hear it first?
I wanna know!
You need to learn!
Right!
It made me super duper happy!
I'm so so surprised and I hope that maybe, maybe one day we can sing it for you, Ruffians, during a Rock n' Rawr Party too!
Yeah, hopefully.
You're surprised too!
If only I was there.
If only I was there live, Ruffians.
You would've heard it.
Still so surprised!
But it was wonderful.
And a big happy birthday to Ina-senpai!
BAU BAU!
And more myth news!
Yes!
Kiara-senpai, she just shared a brand new video of her original song, Perfume!
A dance show edition choreography!
Just before she released the music video that was very, very, wow, stylish.
Fashionable!
Fashion icon Kiara-senpai!
But this time, you can get a very close look at the dance formations.
And Kiara-senpai, of course there's Kiara-senpai, but there's also six other background dancers!
And Miyuki-sensei did the choreography too!
So we hope that you'll go check it out.
Get us a bite of her perfume out there.
But then, doing her best all together.
Seven!
Seven dancers.
Six dancers plus herself.
Seven.
That's how math works.
You know, I just, I love Kiara-senpai.
Her style, you know, her kind of sound that she has in the musical form and I love it too.
Please go watch it and check it out in close depth.
I guess.
In close depth, Moco-chan.
Yes.
BAU BAU!
Hi!
Hi
Autofister.
There is two song covers!
Autofister!
Turing Love.
Turing Love over on Cece's Channel.
Have you listened?
It's so cute, so happy.
Can't not smile, you know.
And the illustrations and everything too!
Just gonna make a video too!
Yeah, you listen, both were so good exactly!
Both, because not just two of them, but also Naimono Nedari on Gigi's channel!
I really love it, you know, you can kind of see two different dynamics of them both really well.
D-Boy Cece.
I don't know. Naimono Nedari,
I always think it's a different song.
It's not very popular.
This one's the popular one, Moco-chan.
But please check it out.
It's very nice to hear them singing in Japanese too, you know?
So you're like, oh, I've heard them, you know, maybe, uh, uh, you know, Gigi sung that song a lot of times, right?
You know, this is maybe a little bit different from that.
Yeah, that one song a lot of times.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
We have a new corner!
A new corner that we're excited to presen- I'm not excited.
I want to be surprised at this.
This show has a new corner, huh?
What's the corner?
Oh!
It's the Biboo accident corner.
Biboo accident.
Yeah.
Biboo!
She found herself in a bit of trouble recently apparently.
In a bit of trouble!
Yes!
Apparently, well Biboo, she was away for a little bit.
But while she was away, apparently, she fell in the gap between the train and the platform.
Poor Biboo!
And maybe Ruffians, if you haven't been to Japan before, you're like, okay, well, um, this is a tiny gap, right?
Sometimes it is not a tiny gap!
A big gap!
And Biboo is tiny!
The thing is, Ruffians, we have told Biboo to be careful of the gap.
FUWAMOCO
I've fallen in the GAP before too, Ruffians!
But it wasn't my fault!
It wasn't my fault!
That's why we know you have to be careful.
The GAP is very dangerous.
Fuwawa has already done it, so we told her the story, and that's why she should have fallen in!
I didn't do it though, see?
You know, there's a mining densha, you know, that really packs a punch.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I think we need to go over and see how Biboo's doing because it's very scary and she's probably very ouch.
Very ouch.
It sounds funny after but...
It is very frightening.
She is probably quite, you know, bruised up.
So please, when you come to Japan, if you come to Japan, please be careful for the gout because it changes depending on what train and what station you're at.
Sometimes it can be very very big.
We have some band-aids.
The thing is, we already have!
We bought her 20 band-aids and we gave them to her!
It's all...
Thank you for watching!
Yeah, Biboo had a bad week.
Hopefully this was just one unpleasant thing and that there was a lot of other really, really good things going on.
But we'll see.
We'll mess with Biboo.
BAU BAU!
Get better soon, Biboo!
Bruises go away fast.
I'm praying, I'm praying.
Sometimes, you know, you get a scratch and you're like, how did that get there?
And then it never disappears for a long time, huh?
Sometimes it's just like that.
BAU BAU.
Oh, Ruffians!
We have another new corner that we're excited to present to you!
We have Nerissa-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun.
Is that the sound of Nerissa-dun?
It's a theme song.
Wow!
It's Nerissa news!
Nerissa has some exciting news!
She released a brand new cover that you can find on streaming services!
Titled The Boy is Mine by Ariana Grande.
Wow, it's a very Nerissa song.
Makes your heart flutter a little bit.
I've never heard this song before.
No, it's Nerissa's song.
I don't know.
I don't know who this Ariana Grande person is.
But... If you haven't checked it out, please go check it out!
She's a demon of song for a reason, Ruffian.
It's nice that she keeps on releasing all these covers.
Why?
Grand day.
Grand day to you!
That's what it sounds like.
Have a grand day!
Fine!
Vey, vey cheerful.
Ground?
I, I, I don't... Grand... Ground day?
Wow!
This song is important!
The point is mine!
Please check it out.
That's the important message.
But!
That's not it!
No, that's not because!
We're gonna end it there.
Oh, no, I wasn't gonna end it there.
In the big big news!
Nerissa is going to be having a 3D musical concert coming up very soon!
The title is Requiem for a Love.
It's Nerissa's very first 3D performance!
It's going to be on May 24th!
It'll be on May 24th at 6.30pm CST!
On the 25th at 8.30am JST!
Look at this!
Look at this illustration here!
And it is a jukebox musical.
I don't know what a jukebox musical is, but it's a musical.
Yeah 3D!
Looking forward to it!
Watch along!
I wish...
That's a demon of sound there.
Alright!
We'll be cheering on Nerissa a bunch!
I can't wait to watch it!
Of course, you know where to go.
Go to Nerissa's channel, okay?
She provides tickets to everybody, so.
Everybody has a ticket.
Including you too!
So make sure that on May 25th, okay?
I'll be there!
And congrats Nerissa!
Congratulations!
See you in the concert of BAU BAU!
Yeah, you're all invited, exactly!
Yeah, it's very funny taking notes, she does it.
She just hands them out.
No verification.
Just throw them to the wind.
Yeah, birds do think differently, it's okay.
Demon guards only have to make sure that the rules are followed.
Yeah, yeah.
BAU BAU!
I'm looking forward to it.
Showtime itsu?
Niijuu-go-nichi no asa hachi-ji sajuu-pun kara hajimarimasu.
Yes, it's from the very beginning of the morning in Japan.
Fuwamoco will be awake.
Of course.
BAU BAU!
So many new corners today!
Right!
Is it because it's a new day, Ruffians?
You only want new corners, though, not old corners.
I want old corners, too!
Right, Ruffians?
Oh, okay.
Don't even need to say anything to the Ruffians.
The Ruffians already start begging.
Moco-chan.
Hi, are you begging?
Hi.
Right, let's give the Ruffians a book.
Yes!
Well, I guess so then.
Ruffians!
It's today!
The middle of the week!
So that means it's time for another FUWAMOCO Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
How are you doing?
You feeling energized?
Hi!
Awake?
Are you awake?
Sleepy?
Could be better.
Yeah?
You feeling energized?
Yeah!
FUWAWA!
Are you feeling energized?
Yeah!
Wow!
Let's get pumped up again!
Hyped up all together!
Yeah!
Ruffians!
You'll say yes after every sentence here, okay?
Yeah?
Promise?
Okay!
Here we go again!
Ruffians!
You work hard!
You do your best!
You make mistakes and that's okay!
We keep learning everyday!
FUWAMOCO does their best too!
You care about FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO cares about you!
Huh?
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
Have another amazing day, Ruffians!
You can conquer it!
I believe!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians are definitely energized now, right?
I'm awake.
You should be because you screamed a lot.
I'm awake!
I'm awake already because
It's the Doggie of the Day!
It's the Doggie of the Day today, huh?
We have... De-den!
We have Porcha!
Porcha's the Doggie of the Day!
Porcha!
BAU BAU!
She has shiny eyes!
Little porky ears too!
A little nose with ghosts!
You know, Po-chan is a sassy baby boy.
You don't even have to tell me, the nose wrinkles say everything.
Right, right, very sassy.
And look at the toy Po-chan has too!
Can you see it?
There are beads!
That's not a chew toy, right?
It's definitely not, right?
Right?
Chillin' okay, Po-chan?
As long as it's, you know, just a hug.
Not like a hug in the mouth.
Not a snack.
Moco-chan, hi there, Po-chan.
BAU BAU!
Hi.
I think Po-chan sounds like... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
I can definitely hear the sauciness in there.
Yeah, that's Po-chan.
Yeah, Po-chan, you know, maybe a little saucy, but that's just a little bit, you know?
That's the attitude!
You know, it just has a big heart!
A big, big heart!
I know!
I was watching our streams together with this Ruffian!
And I... It doesn't have Fuwawa as a chutoi.
Yeah.
You know, I know it's cute, but it just means that Pocha's Fuwawa-oshi.
Ah, maybe.
But you know, I think more than anything though, Pocha loves his Ruffian.
Absolutely loves.
FUWAMOCO 2K!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And for today, I went on a walk!
Ruffians, what have you been heading off to, huh?
We have... De-den!
It's a nice view.
Yeah, nice getting out there between all the nasty weather.
It's beautiful.
The sky!
I can't believe it's already getting so gold.
Right!
Is it hot there?
Is that right?
One more time.
Well, it's already gotten really, really hot here in Tokyo.
All of a sudden, so you know, I can't believe it.
Me neither.
Very aesthetic, very aesthetic, you know.
Pretty and hot, very hot.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Nature!
Ruffians, that was our experience with nature!
There was a spider as well.
BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you for sharing your FUWAMOCO with us!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's question is... De-den!
Do you guys like bubble tea?
What is your favorite order?
Favorite order though!
Can you imagine if we said now?
Bubble tea!
Milk tea!
Coconut Jelly Dollar.
Ah, I like it.
You know, but bubble tea is just so much fun for my friends.
Yeah.
So you know.
I've never had it.
You have to try it then.
It's just really yummy.
Coconut jelly, yeah.
Yeah, coconut jelly is good too.
Jelly that's like coconut.
And normal pearls is always good too.
Right.
But jellies and boba feel weird.
I get that.
But sometimes it works, you know.
It's like...
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Now it's the words.
I always feel conflicted.
But it's bubble tea, feel happy!
It doesn't have to be that serious!
But, you know, I hope that maybe one day we can share bubble teas all together in Advent!
The rest of all, you know, just all like, in a summertime sunset, be like, yeah, it was a fun day here at the bubble tea!
Get bubble tea together, you know, walk home.
Walk home!
In the sunset.
FUWAMOCO, we like bubble tea, but also Mama Puppy likes bubble tea too!
You know, sometimes we'd have it together as a treat when we're young, even when dogs too!
Good memories!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
You've had it before you think!
You know it's a tease and it has like the pearls.
What about Papa Puppy?
Papa Puppy's not interested in that.
Not sweet taste.
FUWAMOCO!
Thank you so much for all your submissions using the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Thank you, Ruffians!
We're always looking for more questions!
Don't give the days away!
Pero Sightings to you all.
So, please let us know with the hashtag, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Abyssgard!
And we have another stream coming up soon.
We have De-den!
Donkey Kong Country 2!
This was the question question question mark on our schedule.
No, it wasn't.
Why would we hide Donkey Kong Country 2 from you, huh?
Why?
Like we said, things are up in the air and they were up in the air and they never came back down.
Someone play Donkey Kong Country 2!
What was the original plan?
We had to say the question, question, question mark.
BAU BAU!
But, we're gonna have a bunch of fun in the Mocchi-Con country too.
We got really really fired last time.
We haven't saved.
The stats is just fiddling.
You know, just on and just going ticka ticka ticka ticka ticka the whole time.
It'll be fine because we need to save.
Otherwise we're in trouble.
So let's hope that the stats is still working.
Because we didn't save before we... Right?
We got too excited and we went on to the next world and we forgot to save.
Exactly, now we gotta beat this level.
We only have so many lives.
Kind of in a tricky spot, but I'm confident.
Moco-chan, you're confident!
Ruffians, you're confident!
You can do it!
Yes!
BAU BAU!
Let's have fun!
We'll be in Boston.
This is the first super karaoke party ever happening here in 3D.
I'm super duper excited.
I'm practicing, preparing lots.
I'm excited to share with the Ruffians.
I'm a little bit nervous about that one song.
That's so... Wait, I wanna buy this, you know, chilling doing karaoke together.
It'll be like a silly, silly... Super karaoke party?
Yeah.
Rock n' Rawr Party, super karaoke party.
Yeah, that one song we haven't sung yet before.
That's so...
We're looking forward to seeing a bunch of Ruffians and BALLISTERS!
BAU BAU!
And that's our schedule!
And then on Sunday the 25th of May, early at 6am PT, kind of like an early FUWAMOCO Morning, but on a Sunday, we're gonna be having a collab together with Roboco-senpai, Towa-senpai, Bae-senpai, Hajime, and Vivi!
And we'll play R.E.P.O.!
This is a first for a lot of us, huh?
I think we haven't really collabed together like this.
FUWAMOCO!
Thank you, Ruffians!
After the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... It's BAU BAU Musical!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Ashin!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!